Good morning John. I'm in a donut. Omnomnomnom.
I'm at Google headquarters. I've had a bit
of a whirlwind week; it's been a little bit
insane, but now, I'm in San Francisco, and
this place is cool. They have little bikes
you can borrow. Take 'em around. We started
off in Seattle, where I saw what I thought
was the largest window ever. And then I went
to Los Angeles and saw a bunch of convention
centers where the windows were much larger
than that one in Seattle. And now I'm at at
Google, which is pretty amazing fairyland
of a place, to be honest.
And now they gave me an o-, I officaly have
an office at Google. Look at me, look at it.
I officially, actually I just walked into
this room. I, I opened the door and I walked
in. 'Cause there's a plug, and there's a desk
and I, I needed to edit my video. Ahhh! Careful,
camera. Don't fall over, you're expensive.
It's weird here. You know how recently, people
found out that Google had been driving a car
that was driving itself, and the driver wasn't
driving, and it was driving all around California,
and nobody knew about it? People who work
on things like that, they call them product
development. Product developers. It's kinda
like saying, uh, my job is that I, uh, I'm
a stuff maker. I make stuff. That almost freaks
me out, like sometimes, you know how recently
scientists said they could, uh, possibly make
a human-chipanzee hybrid? And that's kinda
like an interesting and cool idea, but of
course you never want to do that, it's really
immoral, but it's, scientifically, it's very
fascinating, very fascinating idea. I feel
like 70 floors below me right now, there is
a humanzee. And they're... putting him through
grade school, and you know, maybe they'll
make him a humanzee girlfriend at some point.
Honestly, it's just amazing to see all the
people who come together and make the things
that make our lives better. Ahh, they seem
very happy, like very nice people. The food
is delicious. Almost certain that they're
not making any kind of chimeras. It's really,
it's a good place.
Ahh, and if were to actually curious why I
was in Los Angeles-- Why does my finger smell
like chocolate? Why am I not editing this
out of the video?
Working on Vidcon, I was working on Vidcon
in Los Angeles. And now I'm here at Google
to attend the first Google-only stop of the
Digitour. Which I'm very exited about, and
it may be coming to a place near you. Just
Google it, and there's a good chance it's
gonna be at a city near you. Thank you to
Alex Day for the song that's been playing
in the background of this video. It's called
Hearts, and it's on his album Parrot Stories.
John, I hope that you aren't too jealous that
I am the first vlogbrother that got to go
to Mountain View campus of Google. I will
see you, on a day that is Monday.